oh I leave quite an
impression 5 feet to be
exact you're wondering why I have it's
closed when missing my body's where they
at now I'm gone but you're still
laying next to me one degree of
separation I putur your back together
and if that's true you you just have to
taste me when he's kissing you if you
want forever I bet you do just know
you'll taste me
[Music]
too uhhuh he pins you down on the
carpet makes paintings with his
tongue he's funny now all his jokes
different get who we learned that
from now I'm gone but you're still
laying next to me want a grief
separation your back together and if
that's true you just have to taste me
when he's kissing you if you want
forever now do know you taste me to
every time you close your eyes and feel
his lips you're feeling mine and every
time you breathe his air just know I was
already there you can have them if you
like I've been there done that once or
twice and singing about it don't mean I
care yeah I know I've been know to
share well I hurt your back together and
if that's true you'll just have to taste
me when he's kissing you you w
forever you did know you taste me to
tast you just have to taste me when he's
kissing
[Music]
me yeah ah you just have to taste me
when it's kissing
you hey there friends so this is my
friend Mufasa who hopped out with all
that amazing camera work it has been far
too long since you have been a guest on
on this channel I haven't seen you since
last year
right anyways so Mufasa is an awesome
flow artist in his own right uh Mufasa
where can the good people find you
online yall can find me on Instagram or
YouTube at foro monster awesome go check
this man out he's awesome appreciate it
of course hey friends I hope you enjoyed
that flow as much as I enjoyed creating
it uh Sabrina Carpenter has definitely
become a recent favorite and uh I hope
that uh you enjoy rocking after that
song as much as I do real quickly if
you'd like to get a set of those or po
Pro LED contact po that I was using in
this video you can get 10% off of them
when you use the code Drex factor with a
zero instead of an O at checkout over at
ultra.com once again that is Drex factor
with a zero instead of an o thank you so
much to ultra poy for sponsoring this
video and giving me an excuse to go show
off their wonderful LED po
and uh speaking of thank yous uh I owe
big thanks to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys pyroa light toys and
Ultra poy for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all these amazing companies
and the work that they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that I have down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non- bus friend of
the channel That is Becca Becken thank
you so much for supporting my my channel
my work and my mission and finally uh
this video and all the videos on this
channel would not exist where it not for
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you you all rock
so very much and if you appreciate the
videos that I produce and you'd like to
see me make more of them the best way to
make that happen is to go sign up to
support my work on patreon over at
patreon.com drexfactor poo there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards but better than that you'll be
helping me out in my mission to bring
pois spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world so go check that out please
and thank you and finally if you are
hungry to watch more of my flow videos I
will include a link to a playlist of
those down in the description as well as
up on screen thank you so much for
watching this one I hope it inspired you
to go out and get some flow on yourself
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon take care now peace